This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English, I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
Sam, do you know Stephen Frye?
Hmm, not personally, but I know of him.
Stephen Frye is an English writer and comedian
and is well known for being extremely intelligent
and very knowledgeable about many things,
cultural, historical and linguistic.
To be knowledgeable means to know a lot about something.
I wish I was half as knowledgeable as he is.
Hmm, I wish I were a coarser as knowledgeable.
There is still time, Sam.
And maybe this week's question will help you become
just a little bit more knowledgeable on the topic of the telephone.
The first long-distance telephone call was made in 1876.
Approximately what was the distance of that call?
Was it A, 10 kilometres, B, 15 kilometres or C, 20 kilometres?
What do you think, Sam?
So when you say long-distance...
For the time, yes, remember the telephone was only a baby in 1876.
In that case, I'll say approximately 15 kilometres,
but that's just a guess, a long-distance guess.
We'll find out if you're right at the end of the programme.
Stephen Fry is also known as a technophile.
The suffix file means a lover of that thing.
So a technophile is someone who loves technology.
Fry was a guest on the BBC podcast word of mouth
and was talking about the technology of communication.
It seems he's not a fan of the telephone, but why not?
I think the telephone was a really annoying blip,
in our communications, and that's old technology.
I mean, that's 1880s and 90s.
When you're on the telephone to someone, especially if you're British,
you know, that burning-chore thing,
you know, the moment one Englishman opens his mouth,
another Englishman despises him.
When you're speaking to someone on the telephone,
all the age, class, education, vocabulary all come into play,
because it's in real time and it's embarrassing.
I hate being on the telephone to people.
Especially strangers in shops and things like that,
because it's embarrassing and awkward.
So why doesn't he like the telephone?
Well, he uses a quote from the writer George Burnidge Shaw.
It's not the exact quote, but the meaning is that as soon as an English person speaks,
another English person despises them.
To despise someone is a very strong emotion,
and it means to really hate someone.
So what is it about the English person's voice that leads others to despise them?
Stephen Fry goes on to explain that there's a lot of information about someone
that people get from their voice.
You can make a judgment about someone's age,
level of education,
and class from the way that they speak,
and the vocabulary they use.
Class refers to your economic and social position in a society.
In Britain, we talk about three classes,
upper class, middle class, and working class.
The family into which you are born dictates your class.
These used to be a lot more important in British society,
but there are still different prejudices and negative feelings related to the relationship
between the classes.
Exactly.
So hearing someone's voice on the telephone might make you think something negative
about someone based on very old-fashioned ideas of class.
What makes it worse is that these conversations happen in real time.
This means they're happening live, not recorded,
so you have no time to really think about it.
So he may be a technophile, but he's not a fan of the phone.
Indeed.
He called it a blip,
which is a word for when something is not quite right,
when there's a fault or a mistake,
which is usually not long-lasting.
So do you think he's right?
Well, actually, I don't like to talk to strangers on the phone very much myself,
but that's just me.
But I do think that although the class divisions in British society
are much less obvious and much less important than in the past,
we still do make judgments about people based on how they speak,
and those judgments can often be completely false.
Right, nearly time to review our vocabulary,
but first, let's have the answer to today's question.
The first long-distance telephone call was made in 1876.
Approximately, what was the distance of that call?
Was it A, 10 kilometres, B, 15 kilometres, or C, 20 kilometres?
Would you think Sam?
I guess 15 kilometres, but it was just a guess.
Well, sadly, on this occasion, it was not a correct guess.
The correct answer is approximately 10 kilometres or six miles.
Congratulations, if you got that right.
Now on with the vocabulary.
We started with the adjective knowledgeable,
which means knowing a lot about something.
A technophile is someone who loves technology.
To despise someone is to hate someone strongly.
Class refers to a group in society you were said to belong to from your birth.
Certain stereotypes are often attached to different classes
to do with intelligence and education, for example.
In real time is an expression that means happening live without any pauses or breaks.
So, for example, you aren't listening to this programme in real time.
Well, I am.
Well, of course, you are Neil, because you are here with me as we are recording.
But if you're listening to the podcast, it's no longer real time.
It's been recorded and edited.
And we had one other word, didn't we?
Yes, a blip, which is a temporary fault or mistake.
Well, that's all we've got for this programme.
For more, find us on Facebook, Twitter, Instagram and our YouTube pages,
and of course, our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com,
where you can find all kinds of other programmes and videos and activities
to help you improve your English.
Thank you for joining us and goodbye.
Bye!